wobei ok als ich wills übertreiben also
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel achtung
scheiße oh mein gott oh mein gott was
leute bevor es mit dem video losgehen
auch noch keine ankündigung ich habe
mich heute irgendwie nicht so mega fit
gefühlt deswegen wundert euch nicht wenn
ich ein video bisschen komisch rüber
kommen kann euch heute den ganzen tag
schon wieder platt deswegen auch diese
komische grufti aufzug ist aber alles
gut mir wollte ich nur vorweg mal gesagt
haben damit das keiner missversteht und
jetzt los wie die mini server setzt
jetzt an herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video wir probieren heute mal was
besonderes zwar lässt mir heute in
texture pack aus also ich bin ehrlich
gesagt nicht so der typ für diese
klassischen textchat vorstellung mit wir
zeigen alle items von a bis z laufen
sich irgendeine singleplayer welt oder
so deswegen testen heute das texture
pack ma's durch zeigen möchte dass angry
birds texture pack in jump league und so
sieht das ganze dann aus hier also haben
wir ein verändertes menü also wir sehen
hier schon mal dass hier auch das ganze
mini deutlich anders aussehen überall so
gelbe buttons bisschen schwierig zu
lesen aber ich gehe das fit ist wie
gesagt kombiniert mit dem lexus shader
aber man muss sagen so vom ersten
eindruck her ist dieses angry birds
texture pack ganz nice wir haben hier
haben wir teilweise pilze also die pilze
sind selbst angry birds und die blöcke
sind auch stark verändert von der optik
her fackeln sind anders es ist
grundlegend alles anders und was auch
ein wichtiges detail ist die skeletons
sind anders sie will jetzt erstmal auch
an das ist doch irgendwie so ich glaube
es nehmen wie die schweine seien die
birds man dass hier was für eine kreatur
ist wir möchten kleinen praxistest
machen wie gesagt ziemlich gucken wie
sich beim zocken anfühlt wie es aussieht
und ich glaube das hier ist ein neuer
stern dieser blaue wir haben hier
schwamm schwamm brücke sind das schwimme
ich glaube ich glaube dass diesen schwer
mit aus den haben sie die grüne schweine
gemacht macht auf jeden fall sinn so die
texturen für sandstein ist das glaube
ich haben sie auch schon auf jeden fall
verändert
ein bisschen kleines nico jugend zu
nehmen sehen wir einige interessante
blöcke und jetzt geht's los
ok als erstes mal die die sonne sieht
hier schon mal special aus keiner muss
es sein soll ist das ein angry birds
selbst oder es ist irgendwie ein fucking
gelbes kind was roten bart hat mir ohne
wirtsleute ich bin nicht so der allzu
große an angry birds neid ich hab das
früher natürlich gespielt
selbstverständlich aber verletzt nicht
mehr so den mega teil davon einfach weil
die angry birds phase für mich schon
einige zeit zurückliegt deswegen seid
mir nicht böse wenn ich nicht jeden
einzelnen erkenne aber hier wir haben
den bogen der sieht aus wie ein
schraubenschlüssel gold barren gold
harnisch gold stiefel okay bis 19
japanische stiefel der bogen sieht aus
wie ein schraubenschlüssel oder aber
eine steinschleuder ich glaube so eine
steinschleuder darstellen
dieses blau linda und der gold blog ist
ein alter schwede
wir haben eine animation für den block
der herbst der golfkrieg einfach eine
e-mail die sonnenbrille aufgesetzt
das ist richtig geil
das ist echt stark animierte blöcke das
habe ich noch nie im text gepäck gehabt
ich gesagt ich bin nicht so der text
objekt freak aber das habe ich nie
gehabt das finde ich eigentlich ganz
geil aus und hier noch die goldstädter
drauf ist natürlich auch ein reverse ich
glaube in dem text wenn wir überall
einfach irgendwelche birds sehen der
nada christel der unten haben sie auch
in schwei zusammengequetscht
sorry boss sieht aber alles soweit ganz
gut aus auch hier das soll
und so sieht unsere klassische ändert
gestern aus falls sie mich bemerkt hat
ist ein grün schwein dem irgendwas auf
den kopf gedrückt wurde
auch hier wenn die schweine harzer
quetscht die apfel sieht normal aus gold
hermes leicht verändert gold stiefel
haben merkel im stand der goldhelm hat
diese leichte zacken wie bei irgendeinem
samurai es erinnert mich an samurai ich
gesagt aber alles in allem macht das
texture pack in echt guten eindruck ich
hätte mich ärgert dass das texture pack
er sowas ist alles okay ja es ist ganz
witzig angry birds texture pack hahahaha
lustig für einmaliges spielen aber das
texture pack ist echt nice gemacht sieht
wirklich gut aus man sagen hier ok aller
sie normal aus gold budget verrottet das
fleisch kann ich jetzt nicht so zu
ordnen welches wesen das sein soll
aber wie gesagt die optik ist sehr sehr
nahe was haben wir hier ein spinnennetz
und eine roos rindfleisch rohes
rindfleisch ist ein ei und spinnennetz
ist sieht aus wie eine blase und dann
sehen wir mal zu was wir nicht allzu
lange rumtrödeln denen die anderen sind
da ganz fix sagt sagte gneist ein
schwert werkbank ketten hose weil alles
klappt pfeile sind diese kleinen blauen
birds 8 genau die kleinen blauen kenne
ich glaub ich noch diese kleinen leute
doch die die sich aufgeteilt haben in
der luft wenn man auf dem bildschirm
gedrückt hat dann die sich aufgeteilt
meine ich oder weil es nicht so so und
die werkbank hier ist irgendwas mit
irgendwas drauf wenn wir gleich mal mdm
ausprobieren die platzieren aber erstmal
ein bisschen gas geben so weisen stiefel
gold hat nicht vor aber eine ganz neue
idee dass die pfeile auch engel
als sind wir zu dem text effect 1 2
runden gespielt es ist echt ein solides
ding ich hätte wirklich gedacht es wäre
mehr so eine expertin aus scheiße
gemacht aber es ist echt eine saubere
sache so hier noch mehr eier carouge und
ketten haube altena ist die kette hubert
augen
oh ja leute bis auf jeden fall auswärts
aufziehen weg mit dem gold jährlich
samurai ist von vorgestern
heute trägt man helme mit augen ja alte
das ist geil
das ist geil noch die kette schnell
anziehen [ __ ] is black aber koks weiß
man zumindest ein bisschen wieder
aufgeholt hier gibt es darunter ja sehr
schön sagt okay alles klar geht das ja
das geht auf jeden fall okay alles klar
und wenn man ohne sprinten springt also
einfach nur raus laufen dann
funktioniert auch das hier so einen
körper wasser mal hier drin ein
gebratenes hühnchen oder um es noch
nicht gesehen haben gebratenes hühnchen
ist in eisenbahnen noch eine werkbank
kunden eisen helm okay der eisernen ich
auch ganz geile aus aber ganz ehrlich
wenn es so aussieht
dann behalte ich auf jeden fall den
chain herrmann ich mein checkpoint sehr
schön alles klar
module noch gibt es auch ein etwas
längeres mich würde mal interessieren
wie seht ihr das so also wie gesagt ich
bin der meinung dass man das texture
pack durch ausspielen kann auch
dauerhaft spielen kann ohne das ist ein
jetzt zu sehr nervt schreibt man die
kommentare aus der dazu meint wobei ok
als ich wills übertreiben also
vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel achtung
scheiße wo mein gott oh mein gott was
schnitt älter mein gott
die sind überall seht ihr das ohr jungs
diese wand ok den stammaktien 1 kommt
bordeaux an
j wie einfach genug bekommen hat sie
herr wti etwas im spiel muss man ok ok
wagten mega stranger faktor kommt der
nächste
mister waren eisen drin gewesen ich kann
es überhaupt eine chance hat jetzt die
akkus oder hier wartet auf reisen ja und
ein stick und 150 hat sich mehr gereicht
aufwärts weisen jedenfalls wären diese
zwei ultra schweren vögel auf dem bogen
pfeile okay so sieht der bogen aus den
charts strange würde ich sagen
mal gucken was er uns nicht sieht sagt
zack zack zack zack zack zack
und das hier mitnehmen eisenherz dabei
ok jetzt bereits für den rechts
verliehen
ja vielleicht nicht auf vielleicht kann
er mit dem bogen bisschen arbeiten im
verein ist
und noch nicht das sollte reichen das
sollte reichen wobei wir haben noch ein
leben wir gehen auf nummer sicher
wir gehen auf nummer sicher overknee
jetzt die anderen ab das gibt's doch
nicht nein kann man so viel pech haben
die anderen so hart präpariert mit
unserem fall oder rollator laut arbeitet
nicht so gut es ihr könnt mir da sah man
übrigens die spinnweben
wir verlieren eisen in köln noch
irgendwas ok in eisen brustpanzer können
aussteller anziehen
zack bumm umso besser ansonsten keks
habe ja noch am start your fucking sagt
jeder ich sehe mir die gegner gar nicht
kommen mit diesem text steckt also was
visibility angeht gibt es minuspunkte
hat ihn dir schwert um einen gott hat in
fucking deal schwert mein gott da war
mein junge rennt und die stadt ihnen
auch nachdem die stadt an doch gerade
eben der beides nicht ohne sie
anzugreifen
seht ihr dass sie team einfach eiskalt
die firma kurz wir können uns kriegt man
rohes rindfleisch
da kommt der nächste gegner wir haben
angst um unser leben müssen weg krenauer
kassieren zwei hits dann sind wir sind
down
ach du scheiße also leute dass angry
birds sechser pack ist vielleicht nicht
das beste texture pack um eine
superleistung europa zu bringen
aber es sieht wirklich ganz nice aus
auch wenn es ein bisschen creepy ist in
der das match arena über all diese vögel
sind aber es gibt nicht ein plus für die
engagierten bürger wie gesagt sieht gut
aus ist aber ein pädophil nicht so super
gut spiele was man daran erkannte dass
wir jetzt gerade eben einfach die gegner
gar nicht haben kommen sehen
vielleicht nicht das beste pop weck aber
durchaus ganz nice in diesem sinne
allein macht's gut bis zum nächsten
video wie gesagt download in der
beschreibung und